okay folks we are here in San Francisco
with Roman the game director on for
honor because we just got the chance to
play as three new warriors a whole new
mode let's start off with the biggest
fears just looking of them all I mean
they all look fierce but the SH ago key
with that mask it should go to you oh
it's something that passion right yes
the character that has the biggest HP
pool of the game and by default it can't
be interrupted it too is that actually
did so much momentum in strikes that you
can't interrupt him look that is
strength the cut is the character really
about trading blows with you like yeah I
know you're gonna eat me I'm gonna eat
you other and I'm stronger than you one
of the characters that we played as
today the warlord saw him in action for
the first time might be able to go
toe-to-toe with the Chicago key with
that big shield and big sword what all
is the big biking is the Viking poster
boy he has that big round shield the
glad you he has that look and read the
basic strategy with the Wallow that's
why he attacks uses shield protection
zone so usually the character that we
are when they attack there is a
difference that's not the case of the
world so you want to use that as your
advantage also since is massive he's
nearly attacked like his head butts are
ready for work
let's talk about the Peacekeeper she
brings something new to combat a new
sort of mechanic that we're seeing this
time for the first time yes the
Peacekeeper is one of the character that
can actually applied it please to his
opponent so she has to weapon that was a
short sword dagger every time she
successfully strike with a dagger you're
gonna bleed and she's gonna take
advantage of that because also she's
really fast and Ajah Ajah doesn't have
that many HP so she's all about getting
into your God making you bleed and
running away we played these three
characters today and we played them in a
new mode elimination mode this is
basically a no respawn on a team duel we
wanted to kill the game mode where your
dad said that and when your team is why
it's finish it over so every blows
matter you can't miss one strike and be
like okay it's good i'm gonna respond
what is interesting so is that you
starts in a jewel if you're not poss do
all the guiding phone click on run away
join with a friend acting somebody or
whatever it's really even if it's it
feels like dueling there is a lot of
teams for a video also it's a friend
gets killed you can go and revived in
this if you kill somebody and didn't
manage to execute because if your
executive can be revived then you need
to get these cops because otherwise one
of his teammates can come if you got
these cops you can't go after somebody
else and we're trying to put do strategy
inside the game mode three new warriors
and elimination mode all coming together
as forerunner approaches the launch next
year februari 14 yes all right times
go to for honor game.com / war to
register for a chance to get into the
action during the beta this January and
for more for honor videos subscribe to
this channel and visit the ub blog